Bố pháp động đợi thí đua thu tướng chính phủ phạm mi truyền nhân mạnh.
Mời mi bởi năm qua, kể tự khi chủ tình hồi chứ mình ra lời kêu gọi thí đua ai Quốc,
tình thần thí đua ai Quốc đã trở thành mạnh 1 sức mạnh,
khơi dậy mạnh mẽ lòng yêu nước, ý chỉ tự lực tự gần của tòan đảng, tòan dân, tòan cunt ra.
Các phong chào thí đua qua các thời kỳ lịch sử đã trở thành sức mạnh nội sinh to lớn,
đưa đất nước, bởi qua muốn văn khó khăn và dành được những tháng lợi về văn.
Nhân này, tay hội bị bốn của đảng là dự kiện chính trị trong đại,
quy định đường lối, mục biểu phát triển của đất nước trong khi người mới,
thu đướng phạm mi truyền cho biết, đất thí đua cao đường này chính là sự dây kết nối giữa thí đển
gái đoạn nước dút để nước ta tăng tốt, bất phá, nỗ lực hoàn thành tháng lợi các một biểu
giấm vụ đã được nghĩ quyết tay hội bị bà của đảng đề ra, với tình thần quyết tâm cao,
hành động quyết liệt và hiểu quả thích hợp. Thủ đứng chính phủ phạm mi truyền yêu cầu các cấp,
các ngày, các địa puân mỗi cán bộ đảng viên công trước viên trước nhất là người đứng đầu
phải là những hạt nhân tiêu biểu thí đua đổi mới tư dùi quyết tâm hành động,
vương máo đi đầu tận tâm công viến kiến tạo phát triển, vý dân phủ vụ.
Cậm đồng dành giật, giành nhân người lo đoạn phải là chung tâm
chủ thể hàng hai thí đua, thí đua giỏi, lao đồng tốt, năng xuất cao,
tinh phong đổi mới sáng tạo, vóa phần tích cửc và công cuộc xây dựng nên kinh tế đông lập
tự trụ và hội nhập sâu dầu, thực chất, hiệu quả, các tưởng lấp nhân dân
tế tục nếu cao lòng yêu nước, các vọng công viến đoàn kết một lòng,
tinh tưởng tự tối vào sự lãnh đạo của năng, ra sức thí đua trong lao đồng sáng xuất,
giữa dinh an nền chặt tử ra hội và bảo vệ mua trường bảo vệ độc lập tử ra của tụ quốc,
thu dẫn chính phủ đế nghị mặt trận tụ quốc Việt Nam, các tổ chức chính trị ra hội,
tế tục phát tri vai trò vi động sự tham gia thường ứng của hội tưởng lấp nhân dân,
phát tri khi thế của 8 sẵn sàng, 3 đam đáng, 3 nhất, 5 suốt phong, 6 dinh 2, gió đại phong,
trong bắt lý trong kinh viên mới, với tinh thần người người thí đua ngành thí đua ngành thí đua ngành thí đua,
thu tự trình khủ phát mình chính chúc bối cá nhân, đều lãnh chính xí thí đua xuống kích trên mọi mặt trận,
phong trao thí đua dành được nhiều tháng lợi to lợn, tạo lập những kí tích mới, đưa đánh nước vân bước
tính vào kính viên phát triển giao mạnh phôn vinh, bán mình và hạnh tục.